Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David, P. I am really, really, really regretting
something I did on the show two weeks ago.
Now someone said, David, if you had to leave
the country, where would you go?
I have no plan to leave the country.
I don't think it's going to be necessary to
leave the country.
But I answered the question anyway, and I
said, Well, I could go back to Argentina any
time because I was born there, so I could.
I can go anytime as a Jewish individual, I
could go to Israel at any time.
I'm working on getting European citizenship
through my grandfather, who fled Poland before,
but I'm not planning to do any OK.
The number of messages I have received now
from people saying, David, I'm canceling my
membership because I don't want to be with
someone who's going to abandon us if the going
gets tough, all these different things, I
regret even talking about it.
And now this is sort of the height of it.
This caller said, David, you planning to leave
makes you seem like the unpatriotic Jew who
will take his capital and leave with no loyalty.
We've gotten to the anti-Semitic tropes part
of the leaving the country timeline.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: He gave my name is Jeff.
I'm calling you about your recent segments
reference you leaving the United States.
If things go with George Harrison, that raises
a couple of concerns.
I think that were born out in Alex Jones's
response to those videos.
The first concern is is that it reinforces
the trope the Jews aren't really patriotic
or good citizens.
And here, you know, things get bad enough
to leave.
Second concern is that promotes the trope
that, you know, Jews are global, said who
will pick up their capital and split for better
markets.
The first sort of trouble.
I'm saying this is a guy who by right may
go to Israel or may go to Spain, but I won't
go to either one of those places, except and
only if I'm a tourist.
If things get bad here, it's only because
we can get bad.
Speaker 1: Guys, I'm not leaving in a true
dystopia, the likes of which I was imagining
when I answered the question, we would all
be looking to leave.
There wouldn't be any more tourism.
It would be an emergency.
We would all be looking for safe haven.
Me being Jewish wouldn't change that.
This was the question asked by the audience
if you were to leave because things got so
bad.
Where would you go?
And it's true if I left.
I'm not going to go to Thailand or Norway,
where I both don't speak the language and
have no way to actually go to legally.
If I left, I would be more likely to go to
Argentina because I was born there or to Israel
for legal reasons, but I'm not planning on
leaving.
And it was clearly a very big mistake to even
entertain the question.
What a disaster.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about
a massive winter storm coming that will stretch
2000 miles.
It is going to hit areas that don't typically
have winter storms and are much less prepared
and have disastrous infrastructure.
Are we looking at another potential episode
of what happened in Texas with electricity
in a bunch of states because this storm is
so widespread?
And if so, what are Republicans going to say
about infrastructure?
Hope it doesn't happen.
We'll talk about it on today's bonus show.
We will also talk about the big headline among
many on the right that for the first time
ever, America's national debt has surpassed
$30 trillion.
What does it actually mean without hyperbole?
We will talk about it.
And lastly, their jury deliberations have
started in the Roy Moore defamation case.
You might have heard we talked about this
case a long time ago.
You might have forgotten about it.
Jury deliberations have started, and we're
going to talk about what's at stake there.
All of those stories and more, I am told.
On today's bonus show, we will be there.
I'm told there's something going on for my
birthday on today's bonus show.
I don't know what it is.
I'm just curious as you are.
Join it.
Join Pacman dot com.
Get instant access.
And we will see you on the bonus show or otherwise
tomorrow.